uh thanks for coming really excited to
be here at my first strange loop my name
is keith adams
i'm an engineer at facebook and uh today
i'm going to be asking you to do
something that might come a little bit
unnaturally for some of you i'm
going to ask you to try taking php
seriously for the next 40 minutes
taking something seriously is not the
same as loving it or even necessarily
liking it
this talk is probably too short for that
but my claim is that php has some actual
affirmative lessons no matter how you
feel about it that you can apply to your
own systems
um and that there are situations where
it actually is the the best tool for the
job
and when people hear me saying this they
tend to look at me like i'm crazy so i
figured it was time to put together one
of these talks so
i never really thought much about php
before i worked at facebook honestly
it seemed like one of those languages
that looks like pearl from across the
room
people seem to use it a lot on the web
people when they talked about it all
sort of had really nasty things to say
about it
whatever um and i started working at
facebook and facebook of course has a
really big investment in this language
it has millions of lines of code as
we'll see
written in it and uh they're sort of the
most precious and irreplaceable code at
facebook in some way
so all the business logic like all the
things that actually know what a message
is or what a group is or you know what a
user is and things like that
those are all in php all those
abstractions
facebook spends a lot of money running
php so this is actually a shot from the
air of
prineville one and two these are two of
the data centers that facebook built
last year
uh primeval 2 is the one on the left
that sort of looks unfinished the one on
the right was prandtl one
primeval one was online by the time this
photo was taken primeval 2 is still
being built
for a sense of scale those little sort
of couple pixel high candy like objects
clustered around the road are
tractor trailers so these are really
large installations
that facebook ends up having to spend
money on to
to build to run their site so you know
it takes a lot of clicking on ads on the
side of the news feed to actually build
one of these things
and so i had to take php seriously for a
lot of the last three years
and uh so this talk is kind of um
is a couple of things it's going to
start off by being an experience report
right so facebook has
had a lot of of line years of code
experience with php
i'm probably going to try to convince
you that php isn't as terrible as you
probably think it is
and i'm going to do some limited
advocacy and then about halfway through
there'll be a surprise so please stay
awake
when i start telling people that i
actually think php is better than
than they think it is and then it's
sometimes the right tool for the job and
all that
there are three sort of category
misunderstandings that usually take
place so a couple of things that i'm not
saying in this talk
i'm not talking about sort of network
effects and legacy and the fact that you
can't rewrite all this code that you've
got in php even though you wish you
could maybe you're in that situation
maybe you're not
but that's not the effects that i'm
talking about today there's also a kind
of reflexive right tool for the job
argument that gets trotted out when
people start complaining about php
um i actually don't think that's
necessarily true like
dos bat shell is never the right tool
for the job right it's strictly
dominated there are things that just
technology has moved on from it's
totally possible for reasonable people
to think php is one of those things
um and also people often make a
connection with sort of the richard
gabriel worse is better philosophy
and this was the idea if you're not
familiar with it richard gabriel is a
member of the list community
who kind of critiqued unix as an
operating system because it
didn't do all these nice things that
sort of the lisp environments did for
you
and he was right at the time but that's
not actually what i'm saying either i'm
not actually i'm claiming better is
better um the parts about php that i
think are good i think are
objectively good and it's interesting by
the way looking back on this because i
kind of reread it a little bit for
making these slides uh you know you kind
of forget unix is actually considered
pretty good these days right like nobody
sort of thinks of unix as this like
weird hacky compromise
you kind of look at its landscape of
competitors unix is kind of the point in
the design space that seems the most
principled and have the most
decent abstractions and all that stuff
um i mean maybe plan nine
is better or something but you know that
in a buck fifty
so uh if you haven't checked in on php
recently stuff that's happened the last
couple years php has gotten a lot more
serious about being a competitive uh
decent language
uh we've brought in traits from scala so
the traits are a mechanism for basically
avoiding code copying
uh we brought in closures so you can
write php in a functional style if
you're so inclined
um we brought in generators so python's
yield statement if you're familiar with
this it's sort of a very um
it's a particular kind of sort of idiom
around continuations that that comes up
a lot and there's syntax for it
um the other thing that's happened has
been what's been me busy for about three
years which is the hip-hop virtual
machine
um so hhvm um hip hop the hip hop
virtual machine is the engine that we
use to run all of facebook as of january
this year
um we think it's fast uh that's uh
and and we also think it has a bunch of
other nice features um
there's this kind of unfortunate
perception that's all our fault and i
understand where it comes from
that we only care about running facebook
with the hip-hop vm it's an open source
project if you go up on github we've got
three or four folks
actually paying attention to you when
you report bugs we really do
want to run your code um we have a blog
post up recently from the group's
manager explaining uh
that we've imported the test suites from
a bunch of
from about 20 of the most popular open
source php application suites and
they're going to be part of the
automated testing regime for hip hop to
make sure that we're not breaking it as
we progress
so let's get into it if you sort of
swing a dead cat on the internet looking
for php criticism
you find a lot of entertaining stuff
right there's a lot of kind of
of ranty sort of somewhat overwrought
but basically fun to read
commentary written about php usually by
people who are experienced programmers
who are encountering php for the first
time
the one of these that was making the
round about a year ago was php a fractal
of bad design
and this is like fun reading even though
i'm about to to claim i don't agree with
his conclusions
um you should read it if you find this
sort of thing entertaining at all
one of my other favorite ones is that
there's a language checklist that some
guys put together which is sort of a mad
lib style fill in the blank way of
critiquing somebody's programming
language project
and a couple of the check boxes relate
to php in funny ways you know one of the
check boxes is you have reinvented php
better but that's still no justification
um and so forth but in general you
realize that like php is just kind of a
self is
treated as a punch line in general and
that's actually strange if you look at
the objective reality we live in
i claim so if you were to think of some
of the most important software projects
in the world
a bunch of them have been done in php
all right so usually most people who are
doing things with software
they have some actual thing they want to
go accomplish out there they have some
dragon they want to go slay
and a bunch of people in the last 10
years or so have picked up the sword
labeled php to go slay that dragon and
that should at least give us a little
bit of pause right i claim these two
facts are actually intention
um it's at least possible that php was a
headwind and that these projects would
have been better if they were using a
good language
but i want you to like check with your
intuition that you really believe that
right do you actually believe
uh for instance that if that if uh
facebook or or wikipedia
were using closure that they'd be more
successful i get to pick on closure
because it's during rich hickeys talk i
know there's no closure fans here
um yeah although all the haskell jokes
get written to closure
lovely languages great people but
seriously um
so you know the real question here is
like if if if our ins
our sense of good and bad is going to be
instrumental instead of aesthetic right
if our sense of good and bad is going to
be
about getting things done you know does
php actually make projects more likely
to succeed or less likely to succeed
and you know looking at facebook's use
of php we're probably about as far from
the design center of php to the extent
that the designers anticipated how
people are going to use php as you can
be
we're on the order of hundreds of
thousands of files of php source code
and those hundreds of thousands of files
comprise tens of millions of lines of
code we release that code 10 times every
week
you know however you feel about facebook
the product it at least works some of
the time for some people
and it is on the it is at least in the
same decimal order of magnitude as the
most complicated software projects in
the world
this is the same sort of general
ballpark as microsoft windows for
instance
and you know i'll also observe having
seen a lot of people who didn't have a
background in php
who are you know good engineers good
good software engineers good programmers
once they ramp up on php which happens
fairly quickly they're incredibly
productive
and these are good people and they'd be
productive in any company and in any
medium
but i've worked with good people in
other companies in other languages and i
still find it surprising
how far how much track you can lay with
php per unit time
um so uh let's
start distilling some of the criticisms
of php here right so if you
if you have kind of boiled down those
entertaining rants what are the actual
interesting examples
um so one big category of problems is
basically that there are the bad kind of
surprises right there are unexpected
behaviors that uh
that cause you to that cause bugs in
real programs uh one of my favorite ones
is just the division by zero
and for that matter division by things
that are zero like so false and null and
so forth
um returns the boolean value false right
so this doesn't throw an exception it
doesn't stop your program
it just returns this kind of weird value
that if you don't explicitly check for
with triple equals
um you're never gonna know that this
division by zero happened this at least
warns
uh though of course php has mechanisms
for suppressing warnings
and large chunks of lots of php codes do
run with warnings suppressed
one of the interesting ones is that
addition and actually all the sort of
binary arithmetic operators
try really really hard to make an
integer out of whatever string you gave
them
and even if they can't make an integer
out of all of it they'll greedily make
an integer out of as much
of it as they could have um so like this
11 abcd thing
plus one xy um if it tries as hard as it
can to make a decimal string
a decimal integer out of those two
strings and just sort of silently gives
up on the rest of it and this one won't
worn this one it just does
um so you're probably thinking okay i'm
getting used to how this probably works
uh so like
zero one two three plus three four five
six even though they're strings
fine it's the integer you know it added
these two decimal integers
uh you know those of you paying sort of
careful attention might be surprised
that that's not an octal constant but
you know it would be an octal constant
outside the quotes but it's decimal
inside the quotes
um so there's a little surprise for you
but then it turns out that the bitwise
operators don't do this the bitwise
operators on strings actually do the
bitwise operations on the ascii
representation of the
of the string and strings are ascii and
so forth
um what else is okay so there's a lot of
confusion about value and reference
semantics uh there are a bunch of sort
of
uh as far as i could tell historically
like ideas that were imported from pearl
in the early days of php that you kind
of can't root out of the language now
so when you call a function with you
know some local variable as a parameter
you know kind of nine times out of ten
weekends and holidays most of may
it's going to copy it most data types
are passed around by copy
logical copy in the case of strings and
arrays
but usually you don't expect it to be
modified but if a user defined object
they're always passed by reference and
there's this other kind of nasty caveat
which is that
you only mark which parameters are by
reference in the definition of a
function
so you'd have to sort of see foo's
definition to know for sure whether
this is actually going to be passed by
reference or not and
of course it's a dynamic language so
everything's late bound so there's
actually no well-posed way for a human
reading this or for that matter compiler
reading this
to know whether a dollar a is modified
by this statement
so this does make code harder to read
one that i didn't find on the internet
but i'll add myself as somebody who's
worked on a php implementation
has been that it leaks this abstraction
of how memory management is implemented
so uh like a lot of these interpreted uh
sort of languages that i tend to call
dynamic algol so like you know lua
python pearl you know things with curly
braces and you know colons in the case
of python
infix notation no types on variables
early implementations of php use
reference counting
unlike most of those other ones it's
still stuck on reference counting
because
uh various things in the language have
exposed the fact that reference counting
is the actual mechanism
for memory management and you could try
and move the language away from it but
you'd actually have you'd actually have
to break some code along the way
so it's a social meta problem to kind of
fix this and this constrains
implementation a lot
naive reference counting is not a great
you know state of the art memory
management technique for the most part
um just you know this isn't an hvm deep
dive but
to give you some idea about if you weigh
the code that's coming out of our just
in time compiler
about 30 percent of it is related to
reference counting like 30 of the bytes
that our jit spits out are related to
reference counting
so this is a pretty big headwind on
implementation performance
um and an unfortunate sort of violation
of some conceptual boundaries here
moving on sort of one of the ones that
you'll see a lot is just that the
standard library is really inconsistent
and dangerous
it's cool that they have higher order
functions it's cool that there's an
array map and array reduce those are
useful
i can never remember whether it goes
array then function or function than
array i just know that they disagree
i remember array reduce goes one way and
array map goes the other way and i
refuse to look it up for these slides
array merge does one of three things
depending on whether you pass it one two
or three arguments
um and there was a enormously huge bug
that was on the front page of the wall
street journal the next day that was
caused by its behavior of re-keying uh
integers so
re-keying integer keys so there was a
bug on facebook where we'd used array
merge and
uh an array that was keyed by user id
got turned into small integers and so
things that should have been happening
for these users were instead happening
for
users that were at harvard in 2006 which
were the people who have low user ids
thank goodness that includes zuck which
you know meant that we found it quicker
my sequel escape string isn't actually
safe it doesn't actually escape the
string
just because somebody somewhere might
have depended on the old behavior of my
sql escape string
there's a my sequel real escape string
um
and you know to be honest with you this
is all totally true this
you know i'm not gonna i'm not gonna try
to argue with any of these things um
these are unforced errors right this did
not
have to be this way um there are you
know historical arguments for how why it
turned out the way it did but i won't
bore you with them as a user of a
language you shouldn't have to care
um and you know php's competitor
languages get this stuff better
if you were doing a php reboot like if
you sort of were inspired by this talk
to go
try and take the lessons of php and
apply them somewhere else um i really do
think you could do a better job
than this stuff so why am i giving this
talk
so php turns out to get three important
things really right and my claim is that
for a lot of applications getting these
three things right is more important
than getting lots of little things that
you can make lousy
blog posts about uh right so
uh those three things are programmer
workflow
state and concurrency these three things
unfortunately are kind of a three-legged
stool they kind of
um together interact a bit so it's good
there's going to be a little bit of
forward references over the next few
slides because you have to talk about
state a little bit to talk about
programmer workflow for instance
but these are you notice that these are
sort of pretty big things right
these are uh state and concurrency are
kind of where a lot of bugs come from
and programmer workflow is you know
arguably one of the most precious things
that you can that you can have going for
you
so the programmer workflow with php and
it tries really really hard to keep you
on these rails much harder than its
competitor languages
is basically that you save and you
reload the page right if you're if
you're developing a web app
you save the php file you modified you
reload the page and that's the entire
workflow there's not a restart the
server step
there's not a you know re-parse the
configuration file step
and in fact it turns out its handling of
state actually keeps some bozo in the
cube next to you from checking in
code that does introduce a re-parse the
configuration file step
what does this mean why should we care
well the short feedback cycle has
impact on human psychology right the
programs are written by human animals
they're written by people with limited
cognitive abilities
one of the most precious cognitive
resources you have is your short term
memory
so once you actually get the sort of
state of a program into your head
it's very volatile um and if you're a
person like me who's a c plus plus
compiler a c
c plus plus user and there's a compiler
and a linker between sort of
the thing you were trying and the
feedback from it um honestly sort of 20
or 30 percent of the time i forget what
i was doing
um and that's a lot of effort that you
end up wasting over the course of a day
and actual time by the way um so
state php has sort of the web request
as the is identified with the execution
of a program
all php programs are web requests when
you're running in a server
and one of the interesting things about
this is that all php web requests start
out the same
even if i've never seen your code base i
know exactly what state
endpoints in your php application start
in they start with an empty heap with an
empty namespace with no classes defined
with no functions defined
and they're going to bootstrap
themselves up from nothing at all the
same way
every endpoint on facebook does uh it's
po
i mean obviously web apps are stateful
right they do say they remember the fact
that you logged in they remember your
name they remember who you sent messages
to and all those good things
but that statefulness is not a first
class thing right there's no global
place where you can put things and then
de-reference it with a dollar sign the
way you touch all the other php data in
your program
uh to mess things up across requests
so this is this is actually really
expensive right it means that uh for
instance
on every web requested facebook
something like 10 milliseconds is spent
just kind of
uh you know getting your pants on in the
morning and realizing that you know the
app i'm running today is facebook and
i'm this machine and this data center
and so on and so forth
but in return for that 10 milliseconds
the cost of bugs is reduced
and that's actually an incredibly
powerful lever to pull so why have i
reduced the cost of bugs here it's
because
now a web request is this almost
airtight container for
failure so there's no you know shared
global state that i can run off the
rails by corrupting
with sort of a minor bug that means that
if i check in something that's broken
and i we're serving up bad requests now
i serve up a blank page to you or a 503
but the next request that comes in gets
to start over again as a fresh new empty
php
address space
and finally concurrency which is also
another source of sort of interesting
bugs and problems
and php basically uh most php
programmers will tell you that there is
no concurrency in php
so the model of a web request is that
it's a single thread that runs from sort
of beginning to end and its output is
you know the thing that gets sent over
the socket
however uh there's curl to local host
right there is the web request itself
um there's concurrency at the server
level there's task level concurrency
and so this is shared nothing and it
means that you have a very rigid style
of concurrency you have to express your
concurrent computation as it means that
you have to sort of
package up your arguments for the
concurrent task copy them into it
get some little handle for it run around
do other things eventually pull your
little handle and once the results are
ready you copy the results out
but that's a pretty expressive uh
concurrency
primitive if you think about it it's
actually you know you can dress it up
into lots of other languages concurrency
primitives
um and it has no locks it has no shared
mutable state
you're unlikely even if one of those
subrequests dies in some horrible way
um it returns sort of bad results into
one part of your program but it's still
somewhat contained
this means that you can't there are
things you can't do with php of course
right so you wouldn't want to write a
web server this way you wouldn't want to
write a database server this way or an
operating system kernel or something
but that's fine that's why we have more
than one language i hope that php is not
your only language
um so this little this little trifecta
here of interacting things that they got
right
um workflow concurrency and state
are together i claim a lot more
important than all those little things
that i made fun of earlier
those little things i made fun of
earlier one of the reasons you've heard
of them and one of the reasons you can
sort of get a lot of mileage out of
making fun of them in a talk like this
is that they fit on a slide right you
immediately can see what's funny about
them
it takes sort of months to years to
actually have the value of this
sink into you and while there are other
languages other dynamic languages that
approximate pieces of this especially
with frameworks like frameworks will
sometimes kind of
come close with the concurrency and
state
they don't do quite as good a job
keeping that code in handcuffs as php
does
and that ends up sort of having a value
all of its own which is that
whenever you're reading php code you
know how to read it right you know that
there isn't some shared mutable state
out there somewhere that you need to
worry about because
it's php you know the ending on the file
tells you sort of what the concurrency
model is the ending on the file tells
you what the state model is
and uh you know if you're really buying
this you might be like wow these php
people are incredibly far-seeing and
smart
this is what a great design i mean
i don't believe that this is uh intended
i honestly think this is an emergent
property of interacting
pieces of php like for those of you who
are at the emerging language conference
yesterday
uh you know lots of new languages are
born every day
and most of them die most of them will
never have a program written by anybody
but the inventor of the language
so php was part of a population of
languages that's constantly around us
and it just happened to sort of have
some nice genetic properties that cause
the people using it to fall into a pit
of success
um so you know but that's okay
that's still not you know that's that
still counts i'm not sure that we should
be
prejudiced against it just because it
wasn't a conscious design
now of course php you know facebook's
not happy with php entirely right there
are things that we'd like to do with our
big code base that you can do in java
that we can't do
for instance try renaming a method try
changing the number of parameters to a
method changing the order of the
parameters
actually anything that involves finding
the callers of a method
uh is sort of provably on the wrong side
of the halting problem right you can't
you just can't do it
and there's other things we wish we
could do we wish we could sort of know
that certain invariants in the code
were true right it'd be nice to know
that we only passed escaped strings to
build query
um or that a given array maps strings to
widgets and so forth
at this point you're probably thinking
okay all right hold on keith you're
talking about a type system
um and you're right i probably am
talking about a type system here but
unfortunately type systems have a lot of
baggage that sort of destroys a lot of
the
essential character of php um
usually you have a lot of typing because
there's verbose types
and if you don't have verbose typing you
have bizarre error messages where ghc is
telling you that some file you've never
heard of couldn't unify
some other file you know some type
you've never heard of some other type
you've never heard of
both of these are going to host
programmer productivity and besides
facebook has millions of lines of code
um you know are we gonna convert all of
it
and so this is kind of the surprise yeah
we think we've done this actually
there's a system that we call hack
don't ask about the name too much and
it's a gradual typing system for php
so fitting gradual typing into php
took some novelty you can't just sort of
rip off hindi milner it turns out
because php has subtypes
and to preserve the php workflow we
actually interact with the
the programmer in a different way than
normally is done
um all i mean and by the way the the hip
hop group is a big group and
sort of all these ideas and and concepts
i'm presenting are joint work
um but hack in particular really is the
the intellectual output of a colleague
of mine named julian voilage
more than anybody else and kind of
wanted to really call that out here
because this is
much more julian's baby than mine
um so how what's gradual about hack well
one of the things is that you opt into
it
so if you want hack to check your file
you
start off with the hh signal instead of
php
there are two modes here there's a
strict mode which is basically uh
you know proves soundness like the the
types that are annotated
hack really will not let you through
unless it can prove that you've followed
those types
the default one basically assumes that
information that's missing was correct
so the default approach basically
assumes that uh
that if you didn't annotate your
function for instance um that you must
know how you plan to use it
um and it assumes that if you you know
return some value
um that it's going to fit the the
assumptions that you've encoded in your
annotations
but the parts that are checkable when
you have something that's you know
returning
a check returning a hackify value
it's able to show it to you
uh the workflow here is a little bit
different this type checker has is not
part of the language the normal language
processing runtime
the normal language processing runtime
that sits there and parses your php
and turns it to bytecode and turns those
tracelits and turns it to machine code
and all that stuff
um is actually unmodified by this all it
does is parse this stuff and throw it
away
um the actual type checker is sitting
there listening to the file system and
it also has a channel open to your
editor so we have plugins for vim
emacs and a couple of ides and it sits
there in real time and you know pulls
the file system
uh vi notify and if you're just kind of
hacking things out and you're you know
don't necessarily care about being type
sound yet
you can just ignore this thing or turn
it off or whatever and the system will
continue running just fine
in terms of what this actually looks
like in practice here's like everybody's
favorite toy class it's got a
two-dimensional point
what we had to do to hackify this class
was change the sigil from php to hh
uh tell you that the members are floats
and tell you that the parameters for the
constructors are also floats
and that was it you may have noticed if
you have incredibly eagle eyes
that there actually was an error here uh
i mistyped this arrow x twice
um this is one that c plus plus won't
catch but hack does catch
so an invariant that hack enforces is
that at the end of the constructor
all of your members actually have the
types you said they'd have
we didn't forgot to initialize this
arrow y here
so hack would flag that here's a
something that actually does something
it's uh you know takes two of these
points and tells you their mean distance
to the origin
again it takes two points returns a
float we had to tell pack that
we're also using an anonymous function
here so dist f is a is a lambda that
takes a point and gives you a float
uh we call it two times we stick them in
locals we do some math on them but the
thing to get about this is that
the locals we didn't have to annotate
their type right hax type inference
algorithm was able to tell what was
going on here
a cheat sheet about our type system we
get sort of the atomic php classes so in
float bool
null user defined classes array string
and so forth
we have notation for nullable because
that's an important pattern as people
want to be able to sort of
have the maybe monad as it were um
we have mixed which is a kind of top
type and you know be careful with that
we have lint tools that try to prevent
you from abusing it too badly
tuples closures we have collections so
you notice there are parameters in there
and users can define collections of
their own so there are generics
and we allow you to put constraints on
generics and constraints on generics
mean that
the types that you pass in need to
satisfy the as so for instance
uh foo of t if you want to actually
instantiate foo of t
you need to do so with the type that
implements the interface a
a quick word about type in type
inference here
the fact that php is not block
structured and that sort of there isn't
an initial controlling declaration or
definition of variables makes things a
little weird
so in a program like this dollar x
exists throughout the scope of this
function after executing the cfls
so typical uh you know kind of textbook
type inference works by assigning type
variables to the values in a program
and in a program like this it would
decide okay so alphas
has value a oh wait alpha has value b i
can't unify these two
things they're different types it's an
error
whereas what you'd kind of like to do is
carry around the ambiguity for a while
until something disambiguates it so
what we do instead is we know that alpha
exists but instead of saying alpha is a
we say it's unresolved of a
and it sort of accumulates types as we
see other types that it takes on
and then eventually you do something
that actually you know that's actually
checkable
so for instance you use dollar x as one
of these interfaces and
the type check in that case is you need
to make sure that all of the possible
values of a
uh you know fit and i face
excuse me um so one of the sort of
notorious gotchas with type inference
systems is
you get you know it's cool when it works
the code looks really nice and smooth
but the error messages are
incomprehensible
um so to avoid that we and and this is
actually a bunch of pushback we got as
soon as we tried to get real developers
to do this by the way was that they said
whoa
i've never heard of this file i modified
this file why are you arguing with me
about some file i've never touched
before
so we actually structure these error
messages as a little story
the beginning of the story is there is
an error of this sort here
in the source file and then the the
middle of the story
is why we think it has the type we think
it does
and the end of the story is which type
we think it should have
and in practice this has been sort of a
lot more useful than just raw you know
hey i couldn't unify this type here
so going back to the language checklist
uh we managed to take off two more
things here we invented php but better
um which is still no justification uh
and also the name of our language makes
it impossible to find on google so you
know you'll just have to remember that
hackling.org is you know where our
things are
facebook has millions of lines of code
years of experience with this system so
we really do believe it works
when you're using facebook you're using
hack the majority of new code written
is written in hack and the majority of
developers who write php at facebook
are you know weekly active users of hacc
uh so taking a step back here where do
we see php
uh in its sort of competitive position
related to other languages in the next
couple years
uh php now has uh you know not quite
totally state of the art but getting
their fast virtual machine
uh it has debuggers profilers we've got
these nice integrations with editors
that i referred to before
it has a state of the art gradual typing
system and i'll put this gradual typing
system up there with any gradual typing
system that's out there for
uh for existing dynamic languages if
you're typescript fan
typescript is really cool but typescript
is
the last i checked less sound than hack
is so typescript is more oriented at
tooling
finding colors of a method and things
like that it's sort of human-directed
it's more conservative
meanwhile it's all optional so it's
still php when you want it to be php
and i think php is actually worthy of
consideration for a lot of server-side
web tasks again
um you know if you want sort of if you
basically want know that you want to use
one of these dynamic algo languages
right you want the sort of fast
iteration these languages give you
but you'd like to have sort of some of
the option value that things like java
give you where you know their profilers
and debuggers and ides and you'll be
able to rename methods and refactor in
case you find yourself with millions of
lines of code someday
i think php is actually pretty
competitive in that arena nowadays
i just kind of wanted to give a shout
out to my coworkers in the in the hip
team uh
this is a lot of people's work and lots
of them helped me with this presentation
and slides
so um and with that i'll open to any
questions unless people want to just run
to
break uh yeah
we'll do by row
[Music]
uh we can guarantee yeah so the question
is uh we've got this nullable
annotation and uh what would
go too far i did we've got this nullable
notation question mark ends does that
mean it can never be null if it's just
int
um the cases where it could still be
null or when you are in
a constructor right so if it could be a
you know if it's a member of a class
something that's declared in could still
be know if you're null if you're in a
constructor
or if you're in a private method because
constructors may call private methods
um yeah so with the type erasure
and mixing of untyped and tightened
sub modules um is it ever the case that
people are surprised that a type
annotation
is violated in production
okay so the question is does the fact
that type erasure exists and the
interaction with
these modules exists does it surprise
people that they can be violated in
production
so the strict mode can't be so if you do
want this guarantee there's a
road forward for you um are they
surprised by it in production
so far most of the surprise actually has
been uh the
other way so um it's not entirely true
that we throw these annotations away
so the ones that are on uh member
parameters we actually do check it run
time because
uh ordinary php actually has a way to
specify this
they call them uh they have some name
for them that isn't
accurate they call it type hints even
though they aren't hints um so one of
the reasons the syntax is constrained
here like one
you know there's this inconsistency
where the return type is using the
pascal style colon float
but the parameters are using the type
com type
name comma um it's because the type name
comma thing actually already exists it
was already there
so those ones we leave in and the things
that have been surprising have actually
been people
uh when they when those fail in
production because those are on all the
time
because they're part of core php and
they're on all the time i'm sorry yeah
oh uh so this is from memory uh so don't
quote me on this but
uh we just got this recently
uh you know it's not even up yet so
don't sweat it but it's but if you look
at hvm.com
like we'll say something about it real
soon
sure um so that the hip-hop
vm you really didn't cover in great
detail what's in that so if we were to
go to the website
and pull it down what will we find
inside that video yeah and i've given a
bunch of tech talks on hvm internals by
the way so if you're
curious about this you can like look for
keith adams hvm and find something i've
said about it
what you'll find there is a full custom
sort of language and runtime
implementation
that you know goes all the way from uh
php source code to the fastest machine
code we know how to produce
um so it's a uh it's it's
it's hard to fit into sort of the family
of of approach
it's not really a tracing jit and it's
not really a method at a time jit it's
actually kind of a typed basic block at
a time jit but it's a type specializing
you know just in time compiler that
tries to run your php fast
and tries to do math and registers and
tries to make loops loopy and all that
good stuff
yeah you guys have done a remarkable job
of making phd usable but
in retrospect if you knew
that this project was ultimately going
to look like this would you have stuck
with php or would you
make an initial decision to start at the
php yeah so the question if you didn't
hear it is basically
is it a good thing that facebook you
know was started in php if you
had it to do over again would you have
changed it um i i think if you
tried to do it over again um that you
know basically some competitor would
have won
so if you look in 2006 and you actually
wanted to do something interesting and
dynamic on the web
and you wanted to use a better language
sort of step zero would be screw around
for six months getting that to work
right step zero would have been you know
plug
uh even things like python you know
we're not as mature for dynamic web
stuff at that time i mean it really was
a long time ago
and it stayed that way for years um so i
mean i think at the time it actually
even though it had in some ways was a
worse language than that it is now um
and it had
much worse facilities for abstraction
than it does now for sure
um you know i think that sort of fast
iteration is actually way more important
and if you're you know if you were to
really the crazy thing here that i
actually believe and i'm not kind of
completely stating outright is that
um is that those sort of ergonomic
factors the way that a language kind of
interacts with the larger environment
is actually dominate the things that we
like to talk about when we talk about
languages
we like to talk about languages we like
to talk about eagerness and laziness and
you know copies and references
and memory management all these things
and those are awesome things and i love
working on them and they're really fun
and they do affect your day-to-day sort
of happiness level interacting with the
language for sure
but you know if you're looking at sort
of the impact that the language has on
your success or failure i think
like php has been a net benefit
off yeah but um you talked about
programmer productivity and php yeah
and one thing i've seen a lot is that
languages
where there's a varying course where
people are using
an enforced framework there's it's much
easier for programmers because there's a
paradigm that they already know like mvc
for example
is there something like that for php
where
like switching between php
oh interesting yeah so for those of you
that haven't sort of like worked much in
the php
universe like there's no rails for php
like there's no kind of
dominant framework that is the default
lingua franca for people doing php
a lot of places basically roll their own
um so facebook has its own kind of set
of abstractions that people
think in terms of um so to the best of
my knowledge that still hasn't really
happened and that is like an interesting
sort of cultural environmental weakness
of php i think
yeah a few there's a few folks in reno
that have been working
in nevada actually they're working on
variable
okay l-a-r-a-v-e-l which is an mvc
and they've had really great success
with it so it gives them some
transferable sort of nbc skills
yeah yeah yeah i mean they're
they exist there's like cake php and
there's a few other like things
but but yeah none of them have sort of
gotten total buy-in the way that sort of
like rails kind of pulled ruby along
with it in some ways right
yeah it could be that this is changing
yeah i also sort of um
you know have my particular filters for
what i'm exposed to so
symphony 2 is his candidate but this is
kind of like how it is usually when you
ask a room full of php people about
which php framework is really up and
coming like there's sort of seven of
them that are really up and coming so
it might be like this for a while yeah
what's next
what's next um so uh
we there's a lot of follow through with
hack um so there's stuff that sort of
is not my story to tell about about hack
in terms of going further with the type
system and
doing more flexible interesting things
um there's an there's an endless trail
of performance
right so if you look at uh sort of our
gap to the
you know interpreted php it's pretty
convincing it's probably you know five
to 15 x depending what you're doing
but if you look at sort of where
javascript vms are we're still a couple
years behind javascript vms
so i mean part of it is you know just
make up that deficit there's no
other than reference counting there's no
really hard and fast reason php has to
be any slower than javascript in my
opinion
so there's a lot of performance to to
make up um
and then you know from there we'll see i
mean the world of languages kind of
continues to evolve i wouldn't have seen
um you know five years ago i wouldn't
have seen traits coming for instance
um so you know continue to be generous
in our theft of ideas from other
good languages i guess um
you know i could i could joke around
about julian who's kind of the
mastermind of hack here being an o'camel
guy and say that it's you know it's
abstract data types and pattern matching
and things like that
but i mean who knows maybe that maybe
that's not such a crazy idea
um all right anything else
uh yeah sure sorry sorry
i guess what's the relationship of this
project to the existing pgp internal
project
do you see yourselves like tracking them
or moving ahead of them
yeah so the the question is what our
relationship to sort of php.net php is
there's no genetic relationship this is
different code they're both open source
under the same license so if you can use
php you can use hip hop
um we in terms of language features we
think we've caught up to php54
our goal is probably for the for the
foreseeable future is probably eventual
consistency
with with php.net like they're basically
driving things and we can sort of catch
up with them
every once in a while we get ahead so
like generators was was uh came from
facebook generators
uh we've been using for three years um
but yeah i mean most likely i imagine
there's going to be some kind of
convergence there
where you know we get better at tracking
them
and you know they start taking our ideas
more seriously hopefully too
um yeah
all right cool i'll be here for a while
if anybody has anything else thank you
guys for your time i know it's uh
you know kind of late in the day and
plus we're chicky was here so you know
brock thanks